so this throw he's going to go like this
okay
and
the reason he falls is not because i'm
pulling him backwards
nor
well because his line of gravity is
moving outside his base of support do
you get it
totally different
right through the center
okay
let's fix it
you're just cutting her down
[Music]
no
you're just cutting her down
a little better
[Music]
okay
here
okay frank
dear friend
right here
different
right through
right here
[Music]
go down though go as you go through and
go down through it
[Music]
keep the back foot grounded
and down through it so your fingers will
point down at the end try it again
[Music]
and you smash them smash
you're pulling them down and back
down
[Music]
to enter with the body
means that my body enters where you're
at
they're not not around you
okay
but through you
do you understand so i'm gonna do i'm
gonna
eat me again not on the side of you
through
[Music]
so not on the side of you
but through your base wall and through
that place
through the base
again you can see she goes out right i
displace her i don't
make her go
backwards
okay
so you're on top of her
you're just on top of her chest versus
her hand you you want to just
displace her base
[Music]
push her out
replace her displace means to replace
this place means to reach
great
even if i'm doing gender
[Music]
through your face
okay any questions
or comments yeah go for it
it seems like it's a very precise vector
that you have to get in order to produce
that
springiness driving into okay center
yeah whereas i end up going on the
outside or on the inside and then it's
just a matter of me either turning them
or just being stronger yeah you the
vector is through the center
and you go around the side all you go
around the center because the center is
very heavy
you see that so you take the path of
least resistance but edemi is
really about
yes there is a path of least resistance
but that's only understanding it
externally
so internally
i'm pushing on you
but your resistance is passing through
me
due to my back leg just like at the
beginning coq drills
you push on me your energy goes through
me to my back foot
in this idi me
i push through you and your resistance
goes through me to my back foot
okay so he's
uh he's pushing on me but i'm not
pushing on him
his energy is going push don't you
should be stronger than this okay and
all this is going to my back foot
do you see it's going through me so you
this is all
relaxed his energy is going through me
okay in edemi i can tie so
i'm gonna push through him but his that
same energy of his mass
is gonna go through me
where
to the back foot
okay
so
hence
you cannot have your back foot off
and you cannot have your back foot
ruddering
this this
keeps pushing push push push push push
this cocky drill
is this same drill
in edini
do you understand okay so
if you just like you
[Music]
you brace
and you flex
and you go in your shoulders
all that would be wrong in that first
row it's the same thing here this drill
is loose it's loose it's loose
and it goes through
okay to the back foot tension is going
to stop his energy
at one of those earlier articulation
points okay
all right let's go
okay so
the kochi nugget from
[Music]
works like this i need two people
okay so
relax
at some point he's like this right
okay
and what's gonna happen is energy is
gonna stop this part
but his center's going to keep going
forward
he's going to pull the center and i'm
going to stop that go
this is how he falls you see that
he does not fall by me pulling him
backwards like this
and he does not fall
by me taking his arm you see and going
around him and then dropping it
okay so i'm not going to go here
go outside in here
you have to wait for it
[Music]
i
do the energy
here
it is the same in terms of the hamburg
and the positioning but he runs into it
[Music]
so you have to be patient because you're
more letting his feet go wide you get it
[Music]
right
okay
keep going
let's pick it up
tighten your circles
it's good
good
that's it
[Music]
okay so
is doing straight lines
okay
and i initiate
10 pond it's your energy that does the
throw
and i'm uh
not a straight line you see i'm here
like that you see
push that way
this is what i'm doing no
boom
okay that energy goes through her so
don't turn
so you can be stronger on your bracing
angle
so here you load
your hand
with her center
right and here your center loads your
hand
and see how the feet come up okay
oh sorry where does it load to where do
you think
the back foot again it's the same drill
okay okay
that's it
there you go